we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P here is just a nice, friendly voicemail.
These are relatively rare.
This is high praise for the show and our our
staff.
Take a look.
Hey, Dave, John, just wanted to say thank
you.
I think everyone would agree that you've assembled
a wonderful team around you.
Well, not not everyone would agree.
Not everyone would agree.
But I'm glad that at least some people do.
You should see my my inbox, though.
Not everybody agrees.
You have a sense of the greater good and a
logical discourse that allows others to understand
your point of view, even if they don't agree.
Bravo.
I love the praise.
Unfortunately, Jon is giving a lot of the
people in our in our audience too much credit.
And I'm talking about the haters who don't
understand what I'm talking about.
And they will write to me defiantly and strongly
telling me I was wrong about something I didn't
even say.
That may be actually one of the more, you
know, people say the what about the insults
to the insults, the insults you get used to.
What's very frustrating is getting emails
from people furious with me about something
I didn't say, angry with me about an argument
I didn't make because it just you it's like
punching a paper bag or whatever to try to
punch, trying to punch your way out of a wet
paper bag.
Or maybe there's some other analogy or metaphor
that makes more sense.
Listen, I have something very nice to announce
today.
We've had so much just deep election related
stuff going on that tomorrow, Thursday night,
December 3rd at 8:00 p.m. Eastern, I will
be co hosting a chess tournament with the
international master Levy Rassman.
OK, Levy and I are cohosting this tournament.
It starts at 8:00 p.m. Eastern and you can
join the David Pakman Chess Club at Chess
Dotcom to participate at David Pakman dot
com slash chess David Pakman dotcom slash
chess, David Pakman dotcom slash chess.
That'll redirect you and you can join my chest
dotcom chess club.
This is all free.
I'm not selling you anything other than a
good time.
Tomorrow, starting at 7:00 Eastern, you will
be able to register for the tournament, which
will start at eight.
I will be playing in the tournament and streaming
Lévy.
Rassman will be playing in the tournament
and streaming for the first hour.
It'll be a 90 minute tournament.
The last half hour, Levien and I will be doing
commentary on the games of some of the folks
who will be leading, who are who are in the
lead at that point in time.
No chess experience necessary.
Play a little today.
Get familiar with the game David Pakman dotcom
chess.
I think it will be a great time.
It'll be a great break from politics.
Grandmaster Benjamin Finegold, who's a supporter
of The David Pakman Show, has agreed to play
in the tournament and there may be some other
chess stars who will be playing.
So this is if you if you just want politics,
this isn't for you.
But if you want to participate in the community
and you like the idea of doing something a
little bit different, I hope you will join
us.
David Pakman Dotcom's chest's, join the chess
club, and then tomorrow night you'll be able
to register for the tournament.
All right.
On the bonus show today, we now with the approval
of the FISA coronavirus vaccine in the UK
and that same approval expected here in the
next seven to ten days, we are starting to
see priority lists about who should get the
vaccine first.
In what order do health care workers go before
nursing home residents or not?
These are the types of questions that are
now being discussed and which we will discuss
on today's bonus show.
Also, Brazilian Amazon deforestation has surged.
And lastly, activists have dropped body bags
outside the homes of a number of prominent
Republicans related to the pandemic related
to a desired second coronavirus stimulus.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Get instant access by signing up at Join Pakman
Dotcom.